ah this is gonna be interesting last
time I played visage I kind of rage quit
doing a stall let's just get back right
back into this okay so we're starting
literally it puts you back exactly where
I died which is fantastic because I
can't even see um but I've learnt now
that I really shouldn't be standing
around with the freaking lights are on
and it even tells you this when you pick
it up so I was just an idiot the halls
fricking time but then like I literally
can't see them okay so what I'm gonna do
no what you doing you fool what you
doing where did the candle go what oh
there oh my gosh it just kind of like
disappeared but I thought we had to this
is not fair um I did have to I'm
confused
don't you love playing um free offers
okay um I don't know where these go to
throw up here right and then they go
here oh my god I totally just remembered
what happened f my f f everything where
Wow and there's a freaking demon noises
and I don't know I'm stuck stuck stuck
I'm gonna die now dude dude dude dude
this way this way turn my light and
everything I'll be okay just don't turn
around don't turn around take your pills
just a pill
just sit your pills I'm by my light
already died anything Hey
okay don't do the same thing where did I
even get stuck well that is that room
where that girl was so screw it we're
going in and that's probably why it's
been so lucky because it's probably
something that's gonna happen but hey yo
we literally can't see anyways so what
is my life hi is there is there oh it's
there a place for me to put my freakin
candle down yeah come on get it out get
it out get it out
Oh gotta drop my freakin thing and then
pick up my candle I've really these
controls are making the game unbearable
cannot store the item yeah we'll just
freakin drop it then I've told you to
drop it right okay and then did you do
it
oh I've already got in my hand no no I
just put it away
there you go okay great perfect lovely
Oh cute cute
[Music]
yeah I'm not so sure work oh oh wait is
that like a hole in them
[Music]
this is weird there's a birdcage from
the beginning
takes more pills gonna let my pills no
bad thing we need to keep going cuz it's
hurting
oh great
[Music]
I can't freaking see and there's like oh
[Music]
that's Noah for me to go put a candle
okay I don't like that this game is so
dog like it mm-hmm
yes how do I change my hands ex right
right right
II okay now we've got a fully charged
balls it's jammed
ready can I see can let's see where did
I come from where did I be sorry thing
I don't know did I not just come from
this way
like I'm just walking around in circles
oh yeah she just did it did a circle
okay
okay I'm gonna go this way now
oh jeez I think I see oh god I see yeah
and it's so freakin creepy and I just
can't man I just can't do this okay
[Music]
[Music]
you can for me thank you
- the I can't do this I can't do this
dude is she there I can see a light a
lamp though laughs i'ma coming for your
okay hmm it's getting well done you
freaked me out
royally where as is king come this way
oh my god don't take me forever hey Liam
hmm lamp you're not helping
like you know how sterile um guys I
might just go around the circle's I feel
like I am like when I turn on one lamp
does it just
mom yep
I am actually walking around in circles
I was definitely just yeah
where is key you need the Kade is really
key well can you freaking give it to me
please or I can't progress to your game
okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna have to go back no
okay get back to it all just save turn
pick the scariest probably the game not
working
yeah hopefully that was a glitch cuz I
had no idea was going okay okay okay
okay we know we know that there's lumps
this has put me at an advantage cuz I
didn't know that before I am the
advantaged one holes already sorry about
the state of this game okay so that
didn't actually happen last time so I
don't know why I just screamed I should
have totally seen that coming by I
forgot okay
um oh she's right there Robin's where's
Katie where's Katie I didn't get it
though when do I get it
do I get it now
you know get the skanky
I need the catchy oh my god Jesus Christ
woman
[Music]
I'm guessing that was right I need to
like not go towards the door sigh my
tripod okay not go towards the door not
go towards the door and find the key so
that's what we're gonna do this time I
know you're a little wailing girl but
you're not a happy soul
I know she loved that hey girl
smash the camera girl but I've gotta go
that way deny okay come on men don't
scare me that was my interpretation of
myself
Oh nice painting right fine it's key
wherever it be key where you be oh you
sound too close for comfort
lady
dude there's nowhere else to go you
freaking crazy-ass woman chasing me no I
don't you don't know where to go and I
don't want to find this key and I'm
gonna give up I'm gonna stop playing a
game do you want me to do that I don't
know where this frickin key is you scare
me stop it I'm here but I still ain't
got the key Kenny presence
getting impatient
I saw the key like frickin thing it's
the it's yes yes okay okay right now all
we have to do is read this without dying
let's hope that we can do that she's
close she's close she's too close but I
really can't be bothered anymore like
I'm just going just go in brilliant
fantastic wonderful news
let's go ah this is good this is kids
made progress
I'm not turning around
I don't know if you want me to but I am
not turning around I'm just gonna keep
on going oh I did turn around but the
door was closed to sorry if I miss the
chance - I just want Lee returned shower
turn around
hey wouldn't want the thing to have here
no it's jammed I've gonna turn around
[Music]
help me help me
[Music]
I don't I don't want my candle put the
candle away I miss the wooden bird where
has night come back fine fine
all those is a daddy bed is that the
really creepy teddy Rather's like on the
on the seat I think so that's yeah
that's interest oh hello oh oh oh yeah
cuz she killed the bird honey
what can I open this well that's cute
oh look it's the bird there it is eyes
oh yeah of course there's a door like
what do I do
camera doesn't work here
yeah that all happened in the little
kids room
okay I found a mannequin jaw well that
that's good boys won one of those always
need one of those great mannequin head
jaw instead of a baby features what is
going on yes like the baby fetus is so
much more realistic what wa hell got
myself a little ghostly ghost-like and
right here ah nice I'm glad that there
are candles down here mr. meet mr. Toole
it's feel fuzzy I wish I could just hold
a candle die I don't know I'm not
looking I don't care I don't want to
care the mannequin wasn't there before
that's brilliant where am I going you
guys told me to go down here this is
your fault fidi
tain't oh my god that piece of cloth
freaking scared me okay still can't use
this though right yeah good good good
guys I don't want to to be fair don't
don't really want to yeah cool I built a
mannequin halfway kind of what the hell
just happened
guys I think I missed something pivotal
what that's pretty different all right
and I really need to take some pills
like I am going insane anyway I think
I'm supposed to take yeah take a picture
with the camera okay
no again oh maybe not
whoa
[Music]
what stupid camera I feel sorry for like
everyone in my house I'm sorry people
what it's okay wait wait oh my god
please tell me that you have something
for me in the closet I just want some
pills I don't want to go down but I
don't want to go up well I'm gonna go
down
oh okay good I was like is this gonna be
PT like just the same card or just over
and over again
don't lie
I know but I can't see what am I even
looking at oh okay this scratch marks on
the walls from this thing that's like
harassing me I don't appreciate it oh
hello okay he doesn't like the camera
range well good thing I'm a photographer
Lin let's do this all right gonna get
you gonna getcha
[Music]
gonna get you gonna get you gonna getcha
getcha getcha gonna getcha I'm not gonna
get you oh I can't do this
nope I refuse I gave up I give up
I'm still gonna get where did you go
did he just open all the doors like did
he go through the whole place and
somehow I missed him hey Mary
Hey what I thought I could just hear a
phone ringing oh my just imaginary
things
nice super Monica okay mr. axe
I like the particles in this room it's a
nice spooky touch nope
how the hell are we going
oh my god
he's auto-saving doesn't know that
I can't use my light tonight
I'm just gonna walk I'm not gonna open
any of you but I have a feeling that I
have to yep
you sound different so I'm gonna open
you
maybe it's you yes but you sounded
different to the other one
why did you give me another jump scare
that is not okay
some of them are like see that one's
like a lot higher pitched the in all of
them I can hear them open the angry one
I did like before and I got killed oh
wait is this the angry one like the
bubbling one was like can I get around
to your side
they all sound angry I don't understand
what you want from me to know like am I
just supposed to wait until I can't hear
as much and then just open it I'm ready
this Don willing one is like very very
odd I am a lucky duck I open like four
wardrobes and I was still okay thank you
so much for talking about the whole who
was it mr. Silva thank you very much Oh
[Music]
okay it doesn't let me come right I'm
ready for him ah what is this layout
wait this whole thing I'm just like what
is happening I'm extremely confused I'm
not really go down there kind of wanting
nope not going to
Wow this place is crazy hey panda
interrupt with why did I decide to sit
down on this stupid chair I don't know
but I'm not gonna be
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah yeah put it there
just put it down F great perfect
fabulous
[Music]
it's jammed hey like how little I can
see I really don't feel I'm going
control I don't like not being in
control cuz I don't want to be killed by
that crazy girl okay fine I'm going down
this is so weird
but don't want to stand oh thank you
very much Alan Watts thank you very much
so probably just been killed by her I
don't have a shadow but that thing does
down I go
[Music]
hi candle oh good it's nice kind of kind
of light
oh my gosh okay
no do I go back up now maybe I changed
something
yeah the shot is gone
I left I does that it's like a siren to
let you know like well done
Oh
[Applause]
that's why I was but who was here who
moved it that's the question right
[Music]
don't you love spooky little closets
oh you love spooky little worldlets
what's the reason for making photos so I
can see for like a split second because
my light is not working here
oh my gosh it's those of them
I need the rusty key
dinner it's not water I mean it doesn't
look very appealing I don't think I
should go in here nope
ah
oh gosh Oh God like why do I feel like I
should be running like what is happening
what just hold on
I'm just exploring my surroundings let
me have this let me do that
nope fine then screw you I'm out I'm out
oh is that a way that I can get out of
here
and not die like maybe oh my god this is
bloody Keaney it's gonna be any similar
right maybe it was near I just totally
missed it for those freaking out and it
was okay um great we have the key that
that's perfect let's let's go for some
reason we didn't die this time we did
before so obviously it's kind of like
random
great nope I mean this one
I picked you up Oh oh my god
I can't I can't store it I don't know
what I'm doing I don't know what I'm
doing I'm just I've got a plank I've got
a plank beware beware the plank
thank work like any wack quack quacks
blank now get the climate word we got
the plank go plank friend
[Music]
hey plank where'd you go plank plank is
stuck Oh flag
oh wait Oh God God God God I don't even
know where it's gonna come from and the
plank is stuck oh no this is not fun
this is not fun okay Jackie's gonna come
from here or shoot don't know plank just
come this way come here that come here
that oh my god oh my god
plank go in there plank use thank you
mr. plank oh my god this is so difficult
maybe I'd do it backwards like I just
don't turn around oh it worked yes oh my
gosh the backwards trick work I don't
know how
the irises this way this way it was
trolling me it was trolling me it was
robbing me okay wait I don't think I can
do this so much longer how much longer I
can last
the whole let's jump yes lovely
wonderful I love to jump this house is a
bloody mess okay well I can interrupt
with this me just woke up here I guess
woke up all the rubble
I need to get up Bryce I don't go oh my
god is my camera Pooky are starving I
know I know
oh my candles are gone no no no no no
there's candles here and and pills
that's that's nice I mean they were just
floating I guess the ghost left them for
me okay oh this way okay oh great
and scratch marks scratch scratch one
scratch marks
where do the Squatch wants go too much
signed this side of course so I was just
taking a breather
cuz okay
[Music]
sound here I'm really bad at following
the signs pretty terrible yeah
okay some reason you can't get in the
toilet from that side anymore there's
nothing in here really oh my god
okay actually I was wrong I was terribly
terribly terribly terribly terribly
wrong it's not just that one door that's
jammed both doors jammed and I'm not
turning that light off because I know
that's probably what you want me to do
fine
oh my god I did not know you could do
that and that is the creepiest thing
ever if something was behind that shower
carrying I would've been terrified I am
NOT closing that shower accounting again
bullshitting help
turn off don't waste water
don't waste the water don't waste the
water I don't know what to do
I'm not turning the light off I'm sorry
I'm just not doing it you can do it
again I'll turn the light back on Oh
hold up just in case you do go off again
um oh did I leave the mite off uh-huh
I'm an idiot no that was the light on
it's just way too dark
what are you doing I don't know how to
turn this off I actually don't know
stop it okay well I'm glad I pasted that
let me in here honey
okay I mean it's still jammed
getting into the getting into the bath I
mean personally I wouldn't really go
into a bath a ghost just ran for me I
guess it's been a long hard day
maybe I'm hoping that the guests care
about you I don't know it is the grudge
[Music]
am i playing
what is that what are we looking at here
is that nope
I actually don't know whether it is like
a glow Oh a birdcage I see it now
that's so cool so they're like how we
saw the bodies perform
what's the diagnostic
they're just trying to help
it's not their fault even before we suck
them up she had problems
she killed people for [ __ ] sake
so they're putting on medication that
made her Destin I guess I don't know
what she was prescribed or what her
diagnosis was but I'm guessing it was
some sort of like hallucinogenic thing
because she she was saying she could
hear the devil I don't know if the devil
but she could hear that thing through
the radio couldn't she now we're getting
a present
yes why not we were already got in a
bath of black so
I'm not Lucy I'm like a man wait
[Music]
Marianne yeah sticker off oh my god just
have a little like love heart after like
from everyone is can see you just there
a little girl with hurt your off thank
you for playing oh my gosh wait I can
still wake up what happens now
[Music]
you still keep on playing huh
oh my gosh
so we're having a lot of things in a
sinks oh my gosh that's actually really
well modeled earnest it's very
disgusting but I'm still breaking fees
at the beginning of the game guys or is
that who that man was like he was
telling her to do things like that that
was the demon do do the exact same noise
of where's the noise Silent Hill isn't
it isn't that fun
doo doo doo doo wait so what key is this
for it's for the safe
room 302 room 302 rooms free Oh - why
does that sound like some idiot
can't die now I'm like at the end of the
game I'm just trying to figure out what
this extra doll does 302 I have any
candles which is uh not good yeah I know
but stop stop
[Music]
[Music]
I knew it like every time I play the
game as well as like it's like Sam Hill
the room let me look through the
peephole please don't play with me like
this
can I ask you
that was okay I'm done now
I'm damned I am done I am done I am so
done I am so dad that was amazing I
loved that so so so much like that that
was like I give me the best no I
appreciate that so much
it's hilarious Easter egg after the game
is finished to see the Sun hill for room
again was like because I've actually
been trying to to find this game skins I
want to play Sutton Hill to again I
don't wanna place on hill for the room I
know some people don't like that game
but I really like that game I just
thought it was great like especially the
whole the people thing and the way that
they used your like hotel room just your
safe haven your place of safety was
freaking terrifying and you know after a
while it just got more and more and more
terrifying to be in Sue's either be in
the Sam Hill world or be in your your
hotel room that's being taken over by by
like ghouls and demons and stuff yeah
and it's very good and the whole people
thing I thought was like great anyway
thank you so much for watching sorry it
took really a while but this is gonna be
interesting to try and edit into an
actual video so wish me luck and yeah
I'm gonna go try and calm down now try
and like breathe but let me know in the
comments what you thought of this game
follow me on Twitter and you'll find out
when I'm gonna be live-streaming next
the controls are like the main issue for
me and since you might you might have
been able to tell but everything else
problem that the atmosphere bullets are
great the narrative bits are like really
good sometime
they were lacking a little bit of
direction at the very end there and like
focusing on on just basically confusion
and putting you in pitch black to scare
you which is like what outlasted which
can work but also for me I don't know if
it's different for you let me know but
for me it more frustrates me then scares
me too scares me at first and then I
just get frustrated and I kind of forget
that I'm supposed to be scared
but maybe that's what they're going for
who knows but no the design is great it
looks great it looks really really good
so given that it's it's very creepy and
yeah it definitely has great potential
I'm really excited to see what they're
gonna do with it max